大家好,我是老毛
欢迎来到老毛与指标
这是一个致力于测试各种股市指标和策略的频道
在我的每一个视频中
所有策略将会被手动测试100次
大家好
上一期我们讲了OVV能量潮指标
这一期老毛讲一个挺有意思的指标
并且分享一个这个指标与能量潮一起结合起来用的一个策略
这个策略是老猫最喜欢的策略之一
因为它包含了量价时空四个概念
这个指标就是鳄语指标
Williams Alligator
听名字就知道是Williams发明的又一个指标
在我们之前的视频中已经讲过Williams
所以这里就不再对作者进行展开了
鳄鱼指标是一种使用分形几何学和非线性动力学的移动均线指标
听起来好像有点拗口
不过其实很简单
首先讲一下简单的非线性动力学的移动均线
这里其实指的就是简单移动平均线进行平滑在处理后的均线
这个在大部分图表里都自带
很多平台都有
MT4,MT5,TradingView都自带
属于均线的一种
英文简称SMMA
Smooth Moving Average
然后简单讲一下什么是分形
分形是门学科
老猫就不在这里展开了
简单放个图
你就能知道大概的意思
这棵树
乍一看似乎没什么特别的
但是把左边的分叉稍微仔细看一下
你就会发现这个分叉里也有两个子分叉
而且分叉的形状跟整棵树差不多
然后继续看这个分叉的左边的子分叉
依旧是有两个子分叉
而且子分叉的形状跟整棵树的形状依然是差不多
所以如果我们把这个原理运用到我们K线图上
你可能就会发现
在大周期里边形成的形状
到小周期里边也会不断重复出现
例如周线形成的一个波浪
可能去看一下日线图
在某一个时间也会出现像周线一样的形状
然后再去看一下小时图
又会发现可能小尸图里边
也会出现这样一波走势
这个走势的形状跟日线跟周线
都会有比较相类似的呼应
进入到图表之前
老样子我们先来看一下计算公式
鳄鱼的下巴等于SMMA
Medium Price是三个周期
加上八个位移
然后鳄鱼的牙齿就是SMMA
Medium Price
然后八个周期
然后五个位移
然后嘴唇就对应的就是五个周期
三格位移
然后这里边的Medium Price就是中位数价格
把最高价加上最低价除以二
所以光看计算公式
我们就能知道
鳄鱼指标是不看开盘价和收盘价的
只关注最高价和最低价计算出来的中位数价格
接下来我们到图表中去看一下
好,我们来到了TradingView的图表里
然后这个鳄鱼线已经添加到图表上
我们使用的是默认的设置
13,8,5
然后对应的位移值
可以看到鳄鱼线实际上就是这么三根线
绿色代表鳄鱼的嘴唇
粉红色代表鳄鱼的牙齿
然后蓝色代表它的下额
鳄鱼线实际上就是一个均线的变种
那为什么老猫说它挺有意思呢
因为根据作者的这样的描述
为什么会称之为鳄鱼
因为鳄鱼在张嘴的时候
它就要吃东西
然后一张嘴就是一大口
要吃掉一大块的东西
要等待一定的时间
因为刚吃完了东西以后
它要消化
然后就可能会有一个盘整的时间
盘整之后
又要张嘴
因为肚子饿了
又要吃东西
一张嘴
然后又可以吃掉很多的食物
鳄鱼嘛
就是饥饿的时候
不张嘴的时候
那你就不要操作
什么时候不操作呢
就是它
看到这个区域的地方
都是
这三根线
相互纠缠在一起
没有明显的方向
这个时候鳄鱼是不进食的
那这个时候就是观望
直到鳄鱼开始张嘴
就说明有一个明确的方向了
那就是朝着那个
开口的方向去做多或者做空
实际上这个鳄鱼线之前讲过
这就是用了一个
移动平均线
在平滑处理的这样一个操作
可以看到用了SMMA
然后只用了HL2
就是最高价最低价
属于2的这样一个值
那我们可以快速来比较一下
这里我添加了一根周期为13使用最高价最低价的平均值的这样一个数值
来做这样一个13周期的SMMA
然后我们来跟这个鳄鱼线的下额比较一下
我把这牙齿跟嘴唇的两条线先拿走
我们可以看到这根蓝色就是鳄鱼线的下额
然后这根黄色的线就是我们添加的SMMA
可以看到这两根线实际上是一样的
只不过这里边有一个位移
从这里到这里
可以看到八根线
因为我们这边鳄鱼线这边的下额
它使用了八格的位移
你可以看到
如果我把这个线
拉到这边来的话
可以看到
这边这个鳄鱼线
会延伸到K线还没有形成的时候
因为它就是把之前的数据往前拉
我们现在把鳄鱼线的三根线全部恢复出来
这个鳄鱼线的用法是什么样子呢
如果我们只单一的使用鳄鱼线
基本的用法就是
当这个K线跑到了这个鳄鱼线之上的时候
我们就要开始做多
因为它是一个多头的趋势
你可以把鳄鱼线想象成为一个支撑压力线
如果突破了这个压力
接下来肯定是一个相对来说是一个多头的行情
同样的如果说是空头行情
跌破了这个鳄鱼线
接下来就可能是一波空头的行情
如果在鳄鱼线相互缠绕的区间
那就是一个震荡盘整的行情
对于这个行情就选择不做
因为这个作者Williams他认为
大部分时候都是盘整的行情
只有大概15%到30%的这样的行情
才是一个趋势明显的行情
它的观点是在这些趋势的行情中
我们才有可能赚到钱
如果在一个震荡盘整的这样一个行情里边
实际上是很难赚到钱的
我们交易最重要的四大要素
量、价、时、空
这个鳄鱼线就很好地利用了其中好几个点
比如说价格
这个价格突破这个鳄鱼线的时候
这就体现了价格上的一个突破
然后时间上也会有一个很好的控制
就是鳄鱼线在缠绕的这段时间内
这个时间周期我们就不操作
直到它不在缠绕为止
我们就知道会有一个新的趋势产生
然后空间也是一样
因为鳄鱼它长时间不吃饭
它如果饿了的话
一旦张口
空间就会有非常大
就代表了这个空间
鳄鱼线它没有办法覆盖到量
所以今天老猫带来这个策略呢
我们要把之前一期讲的
这个能量潮指标给添加一下
老猫添加这个OVB之后呢
这个OVB本身是没有这个参数的
但是老猫简单的做了一条OVB的均线
然后用34这个周期来做平均
所以为什么要选择34呢
那也是经过一些测试
然后得出来一个相对来说比较普世性高的这样一个周期
因为实际上我不管是换成21或者换成13
或者换成更小的都没有关系
这个可以根据你自己的做的品种去调试
那这个策略我用到的这个周期呢是34
就是这条蓝色的线
这个OVB实际上就是很简单
就是这条黄色的线
它本身就是一个单线指标
作为一个单线指标
实际上对于我们使用的时候
是非常困难的
因为我们没有一个参考点
不知道这个点是高还是低
只能可以看到这个形态
有个坚持突破或者N型
常见的OVB的使用方式
在上一个视频里面已经讲过
但是这边也稍微提一下
因为我们没有办法来判断它这个到底的点位
或者说是多还是少
所以一旦添加了一根平均线之后
我就可以很清楚的知道这个是向上
然后它是比平均的这个值更多
这是个多头区域
如果它是在这个均线边下
那就是一个空头区域
因为它的成交量不够
不够就会下跌
成交量大的话基本上就会上帧
所以就是这样一个逻辑
当然实际上还有很多的单线指标
可以用这个简单的添加一个平均线的方式
来制作一个双线的指标
可以看一下原代码
就是非常简单
这所有的OVVD计算就是默认的计算方式老猫做的只是在增加了一个EMA
用这个ovv作为EMA的
这个数据
然后使用一个周期来做一个平均
然后得到了一个ovv的EMA平均线
所以我就可以看到这样一个值
好了,就是这样一个鳄鱼线加OVV这样的图形
那为了跟随趋势,我们这里还要再加一条EMA
如果观看老猫早期视频的观众应该可以经常可以看到
老猫喜欢添加一条比较相对长的EMA来判断长期的走势
因为我们尽量是不要做逆势
虽然老猫偶尔也会做一些摸顶猜底的操作
但是非常少
大部分时间都是跟随趋势来做
因为你应该听过趋势就是我们最好的朋友
如果你反着趋势来
当然有可能你的盈亏比或者利润一旦被抓住的话
那个点位可能会非常好
但是你可能经常会被打损
好了我们添加了一条EMA
这条白色的线
然后这个周期是233
因为平时老猫也喜欢用200 100这些整数
那为什么这次用233呢
因为这次所有的这个值
所有的参数都用了菲波纳切的数列
所以我这里用233
因为89144233这些都是菲波纳切数列
那我们用233这一次作为一个长期的
这样一个趋势线的这样一个
一个参考值
对于你用这个长期冰线值
用多少
用55
大家都可以试
老猫用这个233呢
因为一方面观看老猫视频
能知道老猫是经常倾向于
使用菲波纳切数列的
然后来讲解一下
今天要做的这个策略
首先
我们使用了鳄鱼线
鳄鱼线的话
我们要等待这个鳄鱼线的机会
如果我们要做空
所有的这个K线
必须要在这些鳄鱼线的之下
然后呢
我们要等待机会
比如说在这边
看到这个K线
已经走在了长期均线之下
同时呢
这里的能量槽指标
也是在往下行了
可以看到这个点已经是低于了均线值
并且出现了向下弯的这个趋势
然后我们就可以在这里开仓
把止损设置的相对比较小一点
当然你可以用ATR的方式来设置止损
或者前高前低都没有问题
那这边老猫为了方便测试
就是直接放在前高的这样一个位置
这个理论的依据就是
鳄鱼一旦要张口
那它这个张口会很大
所以它不应该再往回走
如果它往回走的话就说明
这个开仓的依据被推翻
那我们就不能去开仓
就必须要止损住场
然后这一波你看这个就
达到1比4的这样一个收益率
这个是开仓的这样的一个策略
但是我们什么时候来平仓呢
那个平仓实际上
如果我们不用固定的盈亏比
因为看老猫视频的人知道
如果我做测试的话
一般都是使用1比1.5
因为我只是要来测试一下
用这个策略的成功率有多少
如果正常要使用这个策略的话
什么时候平仓就是
如果发现这个鳄鱼线开始相互交叉
这个K线跑到了这个嘴唇里边
甚至超过了这个牙齿的这个线
那这个时候就是要一个开始平仓的点了
当然你也可以在下面的这个
OPV这个能量上体现到
它开始往上突破了
所以这就是一个平仓离场的一个信号
上上也是一样
就是可以看到它这边
已经全部站在了鳄鱼线之上
那我们还得等待
因为它还在均线之下
一旦站上了长均线之上
这个能量潮子指标的能量代表
这边是有很强的向上的买的量
这证明了我们这个开仓点是非常好的
那我们就在这里选择做多
然后把这个止损
你可以设置在比较贴近于这个长期均线的附近
或者是这个前面
这个前高前低的地方
因为他一旦下破这个长期均线
就推翻了我们开仓的理由
所以就必须得止准离场
然后这样一波朝上
然后朝上走
知道哪里开始平仓呢
就是这个鳄鱼线
开始跟
绿线跟红线交叉
但是它这边还没有穿过
看这边就很明显
就开始穿过了这根蓝线了
就代表这个
鳄鱼要开始闭上嘴巴了
所以代表闭上嘴巴的时候我们就不做好了就是这样一个结合了能量槽指标鳄鱼线以及移动均线的这样一个策略
它覆盖了量价时空四个要素的这样一个策略
老猫平时也非常喜欢这个策略
因为很少有一个策略可以涵盖所有四个面
接下来老猫会回测100次
看一下这个策略的胜率有多少
为了保证策略的一致性
我们依旧使用1比1.5这个盈亏比
以及1%的风险控制
为了方便统计
我这里用Excel表格来记录每一次交易
0代表亏损
1代表盈利
通过Excel的公式和图表功能
最后我们可以看到最终的盈率
以及资金的变化局限
为了减少视频的时间
我已经把速度调成8倍速
如果你想查看每一笔开仓的点位
以及止损的设置
可以把视频速度调慢
或者按暂停
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
经过100次的回车以后
我们可以看到胜率是63%
盈利率是57.5%
应该算是比较不错的策略了
然后再看一下资金曲线图
可以看到没有什么大起大落
总的来说是一根向上的曲线
相对来说走得比较平稳
这也是老猫比较喜欢的一个资金曲线
最后总结
这个策略使用了三种不同的指标
常规的均线
鳄鱼指标
以及OVV能量潮指标
因而覆盖了量、价、时、空
四个重要的要素
相比较而言
那些无法固权量、价、时、空
所有要素的策略
这个策略的稳定性
应该是相对比较好的
但是使用这个策略
有一点要注意
那就是尽量避免震荡行情
因为这个策略的核心是均线
均线是有严重的滞后性的
所以在震荡的行情中
均线一般都不太准确
好了
这一期关于鳄鱼指标的策略就到这里了
最后
大家觉得本视频有帮助的话
记得按赞和评论
还没关注和订阅的朋友
记得关注和订阅哦
我是老猫,谢谢大家观看,我们下期再见。